pardon pardon ça c'est difficile qu'est
ce que c'est que cette question à la loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime les deux j'aime être une balance
je passe d'une chose à l'autre et toute
chose nourrit l'autre mais je dois dire
que depuis un certain temps l'écriture
me captive particulièrement ça c'est
difficile
j'aime tous les films que j'ai fait des
grands cinéastes
mais voyez vous j'ai un faible pour une
série de télévision que j'ai fait ou
j'ai interprété que colette de 25 ans à
73 ans alors ça c'est le miracle du
cinéma on peut faire du vieillissement
on peut se transformer avec perruque
quand je faisais colette âgées et ça
c'est un petit exploit qui n'arrive
qu'une fois dans la vie on joue ça
oui bien sûr nous avons écrit ensemble
un opéra à deux personnages dont j'écris
les textes et l'ubs les musiques et nous
allons monter ça l'année prochaine
j'ai comme ça quelques petites surprises
à vous soumettre pour les années à venir
tout ce que vous dites bien qu'on sent
qu'est ce que c'est que cette question à
la loi je suis toujours ma cronista
fonds qui d'autre avons nous s'il vous
plaît pour diriger ce pays impossible
que la france et je trouve surtout qu'il
a une rigueur et une flamme que pas
beaucoup de politiciens
écoutez moi j'ai pas voté cette année
aux césar d'abord parce que je n'aimais
pas le film de polanski c'est pas que je
pense que c'est un grand cinéaste
mais je trouvais que c'était pas son
meilleur film de loin et donc j'étais un
peu agacé pour ça pour le cinéma
[Musique]
alors vous savez le cinéma russe est un
grand cinéma
ils ont une école formidable beaucoup
plus sévères et stricte que nolan autre
que la femis et on ne le connaît pas ce
cinéma je ne sais pas pourquoi
probablement parce qu'on connaît pas
leurs acteurs et que donc les
distributeurs sont frileux ne veulent
pas distribuer ses films mais on va
corriger cela heureusement il ya quand
même de diaghilev qui est allé à cannes
serebrennikov qui grâce au scandale à
montrer son film formidable
donc je pense que petit à petit on va
serez à madou et le cinéma russe
[Musique]